un puñado de votantes entra en este
colegio electoral de la capital tunecina
es una escena similar en todo el país
después de la primera ronda de estas
elecciones parlamentarias en diciembre
donde solo hubo un 11% de participación
esta votación se ve como una prueba para
el presidente caiza Hayek y sus reformas
es nuestro deber votar estoy orgulloso
de ser ciudadano tunecino
quiero ser un ejemplo para la juventud y
mis hijos quiero pedir a los ciudadanos
que ejerzan su derecho al voto aunque
sea en blanco muerta la mayoría de los
tunecinos se mantienen alejados de las
urnas desilusionados por el
empeoramiento de la crisis económica y
una creciente pérdida de fe en la clase
política
no voy a votar porque soy pobre y ya he
votado muchas veces en el pasado
buscando un cambio para mejorar Pero al
final no se consiguió nada
los votantes y los partidos políticos de
la oposición también están boicoteando
la votación para enviar un mensaje al
presidente saiet tras su toma de poder
en 2021 suspendió el último parlamento
lo despojó de su autoridad e hizo
reescribir la Constitución para dar más
poder al presidente
dice que sus han sido legales y
necesarias para salvar atunes de años de
estancamiento económico y crisis
política pero sus críticos le acusan de
desmantelar la joven democracia del país
tras el levantamiento Popular de 2011
que desencadenó una ola de protestas en
varios países